Heikki have you ever heard of whitening
tattoos yeah you want to go get one sure
okay are you nervous oh yeah I just
don't want it to hurt too bad I feel
like I'm just not prepared for this kind
of thing people describe it as like a
cat stretch needles we're here a body
electric tattoo in Los Angeles and we
are going to get white ink tattoos this
is very permanent and I hope I don't
regret this now hope it doesn't hurt too
bad that's what I'm worried about
tattoos are fun they're cool it's like a
way to express your body express
yourself and be like this is me at this
moment in life I'm not getting like a
man's name tattooed on my body so that's
always a great start I'm not sure we're
here to get Ryan tattooed you wish
that's not happening oh I think I'll be
fine Oh
oh my god I feel like you're trying to
convince yourself I will be okay so Dale
today you're gonna be doing my first
tattoo ever first tattoo ever and I'm
very good at first tattoos um today I'm
gonna be getting a whiting tattoo on my
ribs and whitening tattoos don't stay
pure white right it's gonna look like a
shade lighter than your tone right now
good as it heals it won't be as vibrant
white on any skin tone it's it's a bit
difficult it's a specialty thing you
can't expect them to be paper white
that's not how tattoos work because of
the melanin in the skin it will always
kind of tone down just a couple shades
lighter than what your skin tone is I
want to get the computer shorthand for
bold which is ctrl + B throughout my
life I'm always trying to shy away from
things and like let other people take
the lead and I have to remember that I
need to be a bold person it'll kind of
just be like a constant reminder so I
want to get let got in black and then
the D in white like let go and let God I
seem to find myself anxious a lot I just
like want to be able to look down at my
wrist as a reminder to let go of these
things and to go back to him one of them
my friends was asking like well why do
you want to get in white ink and I was
like well some of the most bold moves
are subtle right then I'm excited are
you excited very excited let's do this
guy's awesome
maybe like one of your french girls
now just sit down back remember to
breathe and before you know it we will
be done
are you excited nervous you have a very
technical font what are you here to do
like a different look I'm necessarily oh
hey I'm down like hey I like that far
and I'm like that could work if you like
that
pause wait no it's okay so T and eg did
you want to see it yeah actually you
know you're okay right now I can do this
I don't need your hand oh I'm a big girl
I'm glad you're calm and collected
you're not
oh yeah that one feels good I'm gonna
need a good Instagram photo for today
sometimes it actually looks better
around day two or day three that's ink
and irritate just enough the skins gone
day three
check my ground it's gonna be on and
poppin you want to know what feels worse
than getting a tattoo getting your
eyebrows threaded and I guess it gets
easier huh yeah so numb to the pain I
don't feel anything cool you can check
it out oh this is so cool I think it's
gonna look really cool too
oh this is great I like it a lot I'm
very very happy with it it didn't hurt
we'd hit it it was fun it definitely
this badass aspect it actually didn't
like hurt at all it just felt like
really uncomfortable your sits in a
different spot it hurt a lot more than
any of my other tattoo you kinda look
like you were going through it we're
doing like reads an exercise like
breathe through it like I don't like
most people don't have white Igor even
no white ink tattoos exist yeah I think
I like that do you have it being a
little faded cuz like it blends into
your skin a little bit more but you
gotta find the tactical we should get
[ __ ] stamps yes you're just Akeem I
should say gram yes relationship goes
right let's go over there right now I'm
gonna see you